we've just listened to that video of
donald trump saying that he's feeling
much better but there have been these
conflicting reports shall we say about
the president's health as somebody who
knows the inner workings of washington
how open do you think the white house of
being about the condition of the
president
well i don't think they've been terribly
open at all i mean you're right about
conflicting messages
we've had one apparently from the white
house staff mark meadows
uh giving a run down to the white house
pool of reporters which was much more
pessimistic
than anything that donald trump himself
has said or even his personal doctor
sean connelly who came out with a bunch
of white-coated people standing behind
him
so there's a good deal of skepticism
about what his private doctor is saying
and what he trump himself is saying and
i've it's the first time i've seen that
clip of his video from the uh
from the water walter reed hospital and
i'm astonished at the reason he has
given
it seems it's pretty flagrant even by by
trump's standards but the reason he went
to hospital didn't stay in the white
house was he wanted to join the american
people
and and and and and share their
suffering and show leadership
this is rubbish the reason he's in the
hospital is because he needs to for
medical reasons
i guess one of the reasons that there
may be this uh
concern in the white house uh other than
just on how well the president
is is that the election is so close it's
extraordinary this has happened so close
to
the election at a really critical part
of the campaign what do you think is
going to be going on
behind the scenes uh on the trump
campaign
well the answer to the key question
which we do not have and it goes back to
your first question to me
is how thick is this man in reality
is he so sick that he will be disabled
or may even die
so that a new republican candidate
may be necessary to choose to replace
him
that would be the worst case scenario
for the republican party 31 days out
from the
from the election because we we have to
think of we think i have to think of two
donald trumps here
there is donald trump the sitting
president for which the constitution
makes
fairly clear the rules if he is disabled
or dies in office
and then there's donald trump the
candidate for the next
presidency on which the constitution
doesn't say anything at all
so if he is disabled i use that word to
cover
every everything from death downwards um
then the republican national committee
so big bunch a big group of republican
elders
are going to have to take a decision on
whether
uh on how to replace it should it be the
vice president
or should it be a totally different uh
candidate
and it's going to be it's going to be an
agonizing decision for them
in a worse case scenario if however
trump actually comes out of this in
reasonable shape
i think he'll be in a very good position
to cut
the lead which joe biden has over him
now nationally
and in most of the battleground states
because trump will be able to go out on
stage and say
i confronted coronavares and i won
and let's go forward to make america
great again it'll be a potent message
that's very interesting then so you
actually think that if donald trump
recovers if he is starting to get much
better as he claims that he is
it could actually mean that he is has a
real advantage in the election
it could be i mean i'm i'm very
attracted by this hypothesis learning in
the event
it may prove to be totally wrong um but
um
one should not assume that just because
millions of people can now say that
donald trump
told you so you you've been to
nonchalant cavalier about this
about this plague and it's got you and
serves you down well right
that may be the prevailing attitude we
don't know which way this is going to
cut
with the voters we need a few days maybe
a few weeks
before the election but i can see trump
because this is where his
real strength lies if he comes out of
this in reasonable shape
he is a past master at taking advantage
and turning
situations that might look
disadvantageous to him
to his own advantage and i can see him
coming out all triumphalists
all trump-like um and saying i met
coronavirus and i won
very interesting and you can definitely
see that message as donald trump himself
says the next few days you're going to
be really critical in seeing
which of the paths he does go down in
terms of
uh his reaction to kovid 19.
a little earlier you were talking about
the agonizing decision
that republicans would face if he was
incapacitated
what's your sense on what decision they
would make
well i i really don't have a sense here
because
um if if he's disabled in office
the constitution for the 25th amendment
make it makes it
clear that the vice president in this
case mike pence
um would automatically take over the
reins of office
assuming that he himself doesn't get
co-advisement full very serious ill
so far we're told he's getting negative
so i don't think that's going to happen
but if the candidate falls
ill then the republicans have to decide
do they put mike pence forward
as their candidate for the election on
november the 3rd against joe biden
or should they find somebody else
slightly more charismatic and attractive
than
my senses he has all the charisma of a
plank of wood
um so that is going to be the difficulty
for them there are about 160 of them i
think you would have to meet virtually
and
and um and take this decision and it
will not be an easy one
we've just listened to that video of
donald trump saying that he's feeling
much better but there have been these
conflicting reports shall we say about
the president's health as somebody who
knows the inner workings of
washington how open do you think the
white house are being about the
condition of the president
well i don't think they've been terribly
open at all i mean you're right about
conflicting messages
we've had one apparently from the white
house staff mark meadows
uh giving uh a rundown to the white
house pool of reporters which was much
more pessimistic
than anything that donald trump himself
has said or even his personal doctor
sean connelly who came out with a bunch
of white-coated people standing behind
him
so there's a good deal of skepticism
about what his private doctor is saying
and what he trump himself is saying and
i've it's the first time i've seen that
clip of his video from the uh
from the water walter reed hospital and
i'm astonished at the reason he is given
it seems it's pretty flagrant even by by
trump's standards
but the reason he went to hospital
didn't stay in the white house was he
wanted to join the american people
and and and and and share their
suffering and show leadership
this is rubbish the reason he's in the
hospital is because he needs to for
medical reasons
i guess uh one of the reasons that there
may be this uh
concern in the white house uh other than
just
on how well the president is is that the
election is so
close it's extraordinary that has
happened so close to
the election at a really critical part
of the campaign what do you think is
going to be going on behind the scenes
uh on the trump campaign well the answer
to the key question which we do not have
and it goes back to your first question
to me
is how is this man in
reality is he so sick that
he will be disabled or may even die so
that
a new republican candidate may be
necessary to choose
uh to replace him that would be the
worst case scenario for the republican
party 31 days out from the
from the election because we we have to
think of we think i have to think of two
donald trumps here
there is donald trump the sitting
president for which the constitution
makes
fairly clear the rules if he is disabled
or dies in office
and then there's donald trump the
candidate the next
presidency on which the constitution
doesn't say anything at all
so if he is disabled i use that word to
cover
every everything from death downwards um
then the republican national committee
that's a
big bunch a big group of republican
elders
are going to have to take a decision on
whether
uh uh on how to replace it should it be
the vice president
or should it be a totally different uh
candidate
and it's going to be it's going to be an
agonizing decision for them
in a worse case scenario if however
trump actually comes out of this in
reasonable shape
i think he'll be in a very good position
to cut
the lead which joe biden has over him
now nationally
and in most of the battleground states
because trump will be able to go out on
stage and say
i confronted coronavares and i won
and let's go forward to make america
great again
it'll be a potent message that's very
interesting then so you actually think
that if donald trump
recovers if he is starting to get much
better as he claims that he is
it could actually mean that he is has a
real advantage
in the election it could be i mean i'm
very attracted by this hypothesis that
in the event it may prove to be totally
wrong um
but um one should not assume that
just because millions of people can now
say that donald trump told you so
you you've been to nonchalant cavalier
about this
about this plague and it's got you and
serves you down well right
um that may be the prevailing attitude
we don't know which way this is going to
cut
with the voters we need a few days maybe
a few weeks
before the election but i can see trump
because this is where his
real strength lies if he comes out of
this in reasonable shape
he is a past master at taking advantage
and turning
situations that might look
disadvantageous to him
to his own advantage and i can see him
coming out all triumphant
all trump-like um and saying i met
coronavirus and i won
very interesting and you can definitely
see that message as donald trump himself
says the next few days they're going to
be really critical in seeing
which of the paths he does go down in
terms of
his reaction to covid19 a little earlier
you were talking about the agonizing
decision
that republicans would face if he was
incapacitated
what's your sense on what decision they
would make
well i i really don't have a sense here
because
um if if he's disabled in office the
constitution for the 25th amendment make
it
makes it clear that the vice president
in this case mike pence
um would automatically take over the
reins of office
assuming that he himself doesn't get
co-advisement full very seriously ill
so far we're told he's getting negative
so i don't think that's going to happen
but if the candidate falls
ill then the republicans have to decide
do they put mike pence forward
as their candidate for the election on
november the 3rd against joe biden
or should they find somebody else
slightly more charismatic and attractive
than my
sense because he has all the charisma of
a plank of wood
um so that is going to be the difficulty
for them there are about 160 of them i
think we would have to meet virtually
and
and um and take this decision and it
will not be an easy one